друзі всім привіт з краматорська ось
це місце в якому відбулося два дні
назад жахлива трагедія
загинуло 57 людей та
російські здібні на такі звірства
але серед них є особливі звірі друзі
це кадировці їх взагалі немає
національності але вони щоб розуміли вони
добивають самих російських поранених росіян
все розповім про це вам детальніше а ви
підписуйтесь на канал, щоб нічого не
пропустити і ставати нашим спонсорам
якщо у вас є така можливість всього
50 гривень за всі кошти йдуть на допомогу
військовим та цивільним біженцям через
нашу мережу гончаренка центрів по всій
Україні і в тому числі такий центр
працював у краматорську та буквально
останній днів а в ле-мані та на донбасі
наш центр продовжує працювати та
тому ви також можете приєднатися до
цьому правильному справою отже
поїхали ну що ми маємо у нас є
інформація про
якою себе будувати рембо всяких самих
справі зрозуміло, що українська армія
показала на що вони здатні ні на що
ось але на що вони як довели здатні
це грабувати і вбиваєте на бачили і
вбивати не тільки тих, хто
так от
поранених українських
мирних жителів але вони вбивають і росіян
раки про це розповів народний депутат
України
екс-глава збу валентин наливайченка
слухав і для самих російських мішком їх
виявляється командування за Москви до
дало для поранених російських ризикових
команду їх не забирати з київської
області там ще на ту годину та 1 за 1 кв
вже переповнені будеш катували і у
Білорусі і на території Росії книг
він вибрав котрий возить айва куева ти їх
просто кидали у київській області
ти все на малюка в сиртаки йому рукопис
добував зі своєї ми зараз будемо
розбирати все думаєте про щоправда спливе
хто сам ці бандерівці чека справі всі
зуби він російських ризикових олег 1000 за
раз закривається райони ось ми читаємо
наші тіла починають ірпінь раб там на 2
на 3 дуби так ось ті самі там ще за
раз зачистки виявляють ланцюгові видобутих
агресоре до речі взагалі за те що
каже Валентин на нього вже дуже
ображається
російська влада і бастрикін не цей
виродок дав команду який дав одну з
команди все розслідувати напад
україни їй у нього там картам, бо
це наше місто взагалі він дав
командувач розслідувати справу на
наливайченко ну зрозуміло це добрий знак
на віч каже роблю валентина і ось
таке розповідаєш про відпустку кадировці
закордонні загони загони або й
поранених російських добивають до речі
цікава історія я був вчора у
місто дуже
сильно постраждав від окупантів анімації
і мені показали щоденник
одного з російських окупантів сам по
собі своїм рівнем взагалі розвитку
інтелекту ящики в них думки в голові
дам ще інший цікаво він пише тому
що їх там самостріли б три
самогубство але може бути самостріла
можливо кита кадировці застрелили
таке теж можливо, але ми вже не раз вони
говорили і розвінчали сіті кадировського
воїнство це звичайно скоєнні наші
ніку клоуни нам усі яких розповідали
95 відсотків дев'яносто шість він замовк
вже співає це було три тижні тому життя
4 відсотки не можуть три тижні добити та
вже взяли двісті п'ятдесят відсотків
маріуполя загалом ви розумієте з них уже
сміються не тільки в Україні, а й у самій
Росії так стрільців-гіркін розповідає
що все ось ці би їхнє відео як вони
нібито штурмують азовсталь у маріуполі всі
це все абсолютно шайа постановка і вони
туди тільки можуть телепортуватися
хіба що послухайте
набирають чеченські війська які в
Загалом себе показує тільки тим, що в
здебільшого в інтернеті воюють ось лимон
викладати ролики вискакують він
стріляє з гранатомета навіть не
підозрюючи що якби він у бою це
спробував ось
зрізали він би швидше за все там з
ймовірністю відсотків 70 там же і не
дав би
місяця своїми гранатометом не встигнувши
натиснути на кнопку ну ось стрільця
гіркіна точно не відлетиш у коханні до
українці екзотично зрозуміло що правда
є правда і навіть вони її говорять і
визнають одне з найсмішніших пайків
друге бачив середні часи це кадировці
зловили когось алкоголіка у маріуполі
розповідати що це означає а зоні
старим видає військової таємниці поставте на
цю
ch2 такі справи друзі коуна даний є
клоунада насправді повна
відбулася як сказати розвінчання
кадировців про цих рембо справжній
чеченці воюють за україну батальйонах та
джохара дудаєва
шейха мансура я взагалі розмовляв про
цьому з ахмедом закриваємо катер бу
сподвижникам туди його масхадова не
можете подивитися у мене на каналі
інтерв'ю з ним, а ось це всі ті хто
point країну і в них і результати такі
і наш краматорськ ну вам корови теж немає
цим ось це вбивство в краматорську
моторошна яка ви зробили від цього
вмієте проти жінок та дітей касетними
бомбами, які заборонені по всіх
конвенціям і заборонено навіть проти
солдат використовувати а ви використовували
проти мирних людей які просто
хотіли евакуюватися на це не забудемо
не пробачимо обов'язкового сер за це
покараний друзі тримаємо лад слава
україні підписуйтесь на канал і
приєднуйтесь до команди гончаренка центр
тепер це дуже просто